i have some video that i believe is
really going to
improve your week a little bit you're
really going to like this um
the nonsense that press secretary
sarah huckabee sanders gets away with
here in the united states
that so many of uh the trump and other
political spokespeople get away with and
even politicians themselves here in the
united states
it simply wouldn't happen in many parts
of the world and the netherlands is an
example of that as you will see shortly
uh
pete huckstra is the new us ambassador
to the netherlands he's a former
michigan republican congressman
he actually was born in the in the
netherlands so he's i guess
a good choice to be ambassador from
there or at least donald trump thought
so
when he appointed him to that position
pete huckstra
also happens to be on record telling
horrible lies about the netherlands in a
video from 2015
huckster said that there are no go zones
in the netherlands no
go zones are areas where police don't
even go if called right the police are
not even willing to go to these places
because it's so dangerous or horrible or
whatever and
that these no-go zones are no-go zones
because they've been taken over by
islamist radicals
and he also said that dutch politicians
have been set on fire
in a literal sense that they've been
just set ablaze on fire
in the netherlands these are really
specific claims
has any dutch politician been set on
fire you can find a yes or no answer to
that
are there actual no-go zones in the
netherlands the answer to both
questions happens to be no so this
started to get attention a couple of
weeks ago when pete huxtra
told a dutch reporter during an
interview
that it's not true that he ever said
there are no go
zones or politicians in the netherlands
were set on fire
the uh uh interviewer said what do you
mean
you didn't say that and he says no
that's fake news and then like a couple
minutes later in the interview
he denies ever having called it fake
news it's a completely delusional
interview this was a few weeks ago
this is how this all started speaking of
threats
at one point you mentioned in a uh
debate
that there are no go zones in the
netherlands
and that cars and politicians are being
set on fire i didn't say that
that that that is actually an incorrect
statement
um yeah we would call it fake news i
never said that because it's
but he said no it's not what i said the
islamic movement has now
gotten to a point where they have put
europe into chaos
chaos in the netherlands there are cars
uh being burned there are politicians
that are being burned
and yes there are no go zones in the
netherlands
you call it fake news obviously
i didn't call that fake news i didn't
use the word this today
no no i don't think i did okay
so it's already outrageous right he he
first lies and says i never said that
stuff that stuff is fake news and then
he says no
i never called that stuff fake news so
that's the back story that was late
december
cut to this press conference yesterday
where dutch reporters
followed up and they said hey will you
retract
your claim that politicians were burned
and that there are no go
zones or can you provide us with an
example of where a politician was burned
or where there is a no-go zone and he
sat there like a stunned puppy he had
the look on his face that
you know when a dog hears its owner's
voice
uh coming out of an answering machine or
like a recording of their owner's voice
and the dog looks kind of perplexed he
generally recognizes something but it's
not
really actually there the owner's not
there but the voice sounds familiar
that's the expression that pete huckster
had
when he was asked for examples of the no
go zones or burnt politicians
are politicians being burned in the
netherlands in the past is that
something you believe yes or no
i'm not revisiting the issue yes did you
read the quote over the fireplace from
john adams
if you're truly an honest and wise man
would you please take back the remark
about burnt politicians
or name the politician that was burned
in the netherlands
thank you why don't you answer the
question
answer the question this is not how this
works guys come on this is the evidence
you have to answer questions here's how
it continued
with a bit of overlap with the previous
video you'll notice someone i think his
handler or aide says something like
well if there are no more questions take
a look at video number two
answer the question
can you mention maybe any example of a
dutch politician who is burned recent
years
we go to bonnie good morning ambassador
good morning
this is nothing else works guys come on
this is the best night
you have to answer questions please this
is not how it works
this is exactly the strategy i've
suggested
that the white house press corps
employee when sarah huckabee sanders or
trump or whoever doesn't answer a
question
every reporter has to just repeat the
same question until there's an answer
instead of just moving on to whatever
question you had planned and at another
point during this
um a dutch reporter asked
huxtra if he'd be visiting one of those
no-go
areas and i'm not even sure that pete
huxtra understood the
sort of snarky undertone of the question
take a look at this last clip
will you be visiting our no-go areas
it is not about my personal views
anymore right this is about the views
and the policies of the united states of
america
as directed by this administration
so getting away from that question as
quickly as possible
apple doesn't fall from the tree i guess
is the right
phrase here well actually i think he's
been vindicated because they're burning
him at the stake right there
no one's gonna go in and save him too
he's the politician that's proverbially
being burned up seriously american
reporters should take a lesson from this
you do not in any way allow the
non-answers to stand and i like how the
dutch reporters say
this is the netherlands uh we're not
just pretending
that the the question has been answered
and we're moving on and i i just the
best part for me
i don't know who that person that female
voice you hear in the background is
an aide a handler someone who works in
the ambassador's office i don't know
who says well if there's nothing else
here oh no no we've got plenty more
it's just we're trying to get an answer
to this one question
will you say i was wrong there were no
dutch politicians who were burned
uh or i'm gonna give you an example just
embarrassing total face plant here they
certainly do things differently over
there i mean in america
the politicians will obfuscate they'll
use what about ism anyway to not answer
the question and because we're so
desensitized to it
the reporters won't even follow up yeah
it's very very common that you don't uh
you don't see follow-up questions um in
the united states or even just asking
the same question again and it's
the frame has moved so much because
and this is by design our elected
officials in the united states
have very successfully created an
atmosphere we're just repeating a
question just saying
you didn't answer that i'm going to ask
the same question again
they've created an atmosphere where it's
the bad guy reporter who's being overly
aggressive and doing something wrong
when really they're doing their job
that's something that the elected
officials and the establishment has
succeeded at
because the truth is it's them it's the
elected officials
who should be looked at negatively when
they don't answer a question but instead
it's so
backwards here by design that
it's the reporter or interviewer who is
being rude when he merely says
you didn't answer my question let me ask
it again and if the reporter does that
then they come across
as rude and they won't get access for
the next interview then that's
around then you can lose access for sure
um i'm glad that this happened i'm glad
that this happened and i wish it
happened more
in the united states send me your
thoughts if you've watched the video i'm
on twitter at d
pacman and the show is on twitter at
david pakman show
if you've been hearing about bitcoin and
cryptocurrency and you want to get
involved maybe buy a little
but you just don't know how coinbase is
for you
coinbase is the world's most used way to
buy
sell and use bitcoin ethereum
litecoin and bitcoin cash if you sign up
through davidpakman.com
coinbase and buy or transfer a hundred
dollars worth of bitcoin
you'll get a ten dollar bonus and so
will we so you'll be supporting the
david pakman show
sign up today at davidpakman.com
coinbase